y bueno fue muy interesante ver a los
tres presidentes o jefes de estado se
llamaron en varias veces amigos si están
siguiendo esta frase que se usa en
Estados Unidos de los de Los tres amigos
en referencia a una a una película de
Hollywood y cada uno subrayó algún tema
importante eh trudó bien dijo que juntos
los países de la región son más grandes
y más fuertes que hay mucho comercio que
existe en la región ya que fortalecerlo
y continuarlo biden dijo que la
fortaleza de estas tres democracias y
subrayó democracias es su gente y su
diversidad lo cual es muy importante y
habla también de la historia migratoria
de Estados Unidos y la gran cantidad de
mexicanos y latinos que viven en este
país así como en Canadá y el presidente
de México habló de la también de la
amistad de estos tres pueblos de la
necesidad de trabajar conjuntamente
discutió temas de su agenda como su como
ayudar a los a los pobres y
y la lucha contra la corrupción pero
también fue muy interesante ver que él
mencionó la situación en Brasil sobre la
cual los tres presidentes se mostraron
solidarios con el presidente electo Lula
también mencionó a los dijo el hermanos
centroamericanos y le pidió al
presidente biden en este foro que
hiciera una amnistía para la gente que
se encuentra de manera regular en
Estados Unidos viviendo de de origen
mexicano en parte de esta discusión
humanitaria de los temas migratorios en
cuanto al tema migratorio que sin duda
ha marcado la agenda de este encuentro
trilateral se han conocido sin mayores
detalles pequeños acuerdos a los que han
logrado o a los que han llegado estos
tres líderes Como por ejemplo un centro
de información para migrantes y una
plataforma digital para que puedan
acceder a vías legales Pero qué hace
falta en concreto
sí es un tema complicado del cual
conocemos mucho los investigadores de
migración Entonces ahora es mejorar la
situación para que menos gente ponga en
riesgo su vida y que puedan acceder de
manera ordenada y legal a Estados Unidos
Canadá y México para que no veamos estas
imágenes de mucha gente durmiendo a las
calles con frío en espera de de una visa
de trabajo o una oportunidad eh una
oferta de vivienda Entonces si están
haciendo y yo diría programas pilotos
que el gobierno estadounidense con la
ayuda de México está promoviendo está
esta idea de la de la aplicación en
línea para que la gente pueda pedir una
junta con un agente de migración para
pedir el asilo y llegar así ya con la
con la con la aplicación hecha para que
no llegue gente que se presente de
primera vez en la frontera porque Crea
una botella un cuello de botella muchas
líneas y mucha gente apareciendo si uno
su aplicación como lo haría para en el
momento de hoy obtener una visa por
ejemplo entonces llegar uno con una cita
y se vería esto de una manera más
ordenada El problema es que hay
limitaciones de número Entonces estamos
hablando ahorita de 30.000 personas de
cuatro países en un mes y sabemos que la
que la demanda de la gente viajando y en
camino a la frontera de Estados Unidos
es mayor que este número Por lo cual no
solucionará del todo el problema y
mandarlos a México y que México lo
reciba sin darles asilos sin darles
trabajo no es una solución de largo
plazo Pero es mejor que lo que tenemos
ahora
decía el presidente Andrés Manuel López
Obrador que había que abordar el tema de
la migración con un enfoque humanitario
a su percepción cómo está siendo tratado
hasta ahora este tema
desafortunadamente hay una historia de
xenofobia de discriminación de temor a
lo que se le llama la migración e
indocumentada o ilegal que se ve que a
los migrantes son eh pandilleros o que
están rompiendo la ley y esto lo vimos
muy claramente con el presidente Trump y
es algo a lo cual
ha tenido cuidado biden al cual se le
acusa de manera errónea de tener una
frontera abierta entonces biden tiene
una situación compleja porque no tiene
el apoyo de la suprema corte de justicia
no tiene el apoyo del congreso para
hacer una reforma migratoria el día de
hoy Entonces con su habilidad del del
poder ejecutivo tiene que hacer ciertos
cambios para tratar a los a los
migrantes de una manera más humanitaria
sin embargo el problema ahorita con el
título 42 es que se está negando
la la el derecho legal que tiene las
personas de pedir asilo al llegar a la
frontera
disminuir que la gente llegue pidiendo
asilo lo cual no es lo más humanitario
que se puede hacer entonces es un
problema que todavía seguirá Seguiremos
tratando bien hablemos ahora del papel
continúe
Bueno hablemos ahora del papel de Canadá
Cuál ha sido su actuación en medio de
esta crisis migratoria
Canadá ha recibido muchas personas en el
último año se ha recuperado de la gente
que no recibió como refugiados o
inmigrantes legales durante la pandemia
y es una política de estado
con el propósito de aumentar su
población Canadá es una nación que
históricamente también depende para su
crecimiento político económico y de
población de la gente que viene de otros
países Entonces se ve un récord de
migración legal el año pasado lo cual
Canadá necesita porque como muchos
países Estados Unidos México y Canadá
Europa Japón la población está
envejeciendo porque por lo que necesitan
más gente en edad laboral para ayudar a
la economía que de otra manera se vería
el crecimiento económico
disminuido entonces Canadá por su parte
está siendo bastante
el tema de Canadá es un poco diferente
porque al no compartir una frontera con
México Latinoamérica
la gente no puede llegar a a pie
pidiendo el asilo tienen que hacerlo por
vía aérea Por lo cual tienen que tener
una Visa O o este o pedir el asilo en el
aeropuerto que es algo que lo que
Estados Unidos quisiera hacer más que
llegar a la gente como está llegando a
Canadá pero al tener esta gran frontera
con México es algo que es difícil México
ha tratado de cerrar la frontera los
migrantes pero no lo no lo puede hacer
al 100% Bien también hablaba por ejemplo
de la necesidad de hacer de América una
fuerza energética limpia es un tema que
como lo mencionábamos anteriormente
genera un poco de desacuerdo con entre
Estados Unidos y Canadá con el gobierno
mexicano que ha priorizado las energías
fósiles Entonces cómo estos desacuerdos
frenan la posibilidad de llegar a una
solución conjunta
Así es Estados Unidos y Canadá han sido
muy hábiles en en crear crecimiento
económico y ahorros al convertir muchas
industrias a energías más limpias que
también Ahora son más económicas
parte de la agenda de López Obrador en
su campaña era ser tener más soberanía
energética y seguir usando el petróleo
como una fuerte de fuente importante
fuente de ingreso para la hacienda
mexicana y incluso comprar refinerías
incluidas unas una lentejas entonces esa
esa agenda del del poderío digamos con
el petróleo
está en contra de las energías más
limpias sin embargo también dada la
crisis entre Rusia y Ucrania la guerra
no se discute mucho Pero ha sido
importante para el mercado regional El
contar con el con el petróleo mexicano y
que y que en México no es este
exportando y bueno no es importando
tanto petróleo como sería de otra manera
entonces parte de esto es diversificar
las fuentes de energía y es algo que a
largo plazo México también le convendrá
crecer su proporción de de energía
eólica o solar